le gouvernement ouest allemand a
protesté ce soir contre les brutalités
commises la nuit dernière à berlin sur
des équipes de télévision par la police
est allemande ses équipes étaient venues
filmer à l'est des jeunes qui
s'approchaient du mur pour écouter
michael jackson en concert
de l'autre côté à l'ouest emilie raffoul
pink floyd rose hill in eigen samedi
hier soir avec michael jackson c'en
était trop pour les jeunes de berlin est
plusieurs milliers d'entre eux ont tenté
de s'approcher du mur pour écouter le
concert donné à la porte de brandebourg
tout près mais de l'autre côté pas
d'accord les autorités de l'est ont bien
essayé de les détourner
en dernière minute un spectacle top
niveau a été organisée à l'est james
brown quelques groupes de rock et la
patineuse katarina vite en animatrice
vedette bien maigre face à l'attraction
des lumières de l'ouest et du mythique
michael jackson il ya des gros surtout
face à ces jeunes qui chaque année
principe défense est revenue à l'ouest
pour descendre dans la rue et réclamer
la glace nost à l'image de moscou il
faut que ça change disait-il hier soir
le mur doit disparaître ne restait donc
plus que les petits moyens agents de la
sécurité en civil infiltrés parmi les
jeunes deux équipes de télévisions ouest
allemandes ont été brutalement empêchés
de filmer avant d'être chassés à coups
de matraque et plusieurs dizaines de
jeunes ont été arrêtés